[Music]
and welcome back to another awesome
episode of the careful boys and here we
have tesh today what's up ted yeah tesh
i gotta introduce you for every video
you know that oh i know that's the way
it goes i love them so we got a fun
prompt today uh well we really get to
just dive and talk to each other really
learn about each other some more but uh
here's here's the here's the prompt tell
us about a time when you were the
jealous one in a relationship every day
so jealous every day
you know that's kind of romantic when i
was dating this girl and she kept
sitting on other guys laps at the party
you have to fight everything i was so
jealous dude i was like why are you
[ __ ] sitting on their laps and [ __ ]
she goes ah you're so jealous and i'm
like but this kind of feels like a good
reason to be jealous
you're sitting on their laps dude like
did you start sitting on other girls you
sit on other people's lives
no i'm serious you should have sat on
her lap while she's on another yeah she
sat on another dude's lap she was
sitting on guys laps and then drinking
beers and whatever and it was not just
one it'd be like three and then like not
at the same time and then i'm just
sitting there scratching my head and i'm
like we're [ __ ] right now
do you think everyone else was saying
the same thing too
no like we're [ __ ] right now why'd
you hey
like i don't know if she lied but she
was a virgin and she was sitting on
everyone's lap
but you guys were [ __ ] but she was a
virgin
[Laughter]
no i'm the person that
took it away
if she's not lying
is she is she in a sorority no good
question because you know they have
those like oh this is my brother my god
brother my god brother
this is my son
that's the catholic church brother
my god brother
like she was very friendly right and all
that stuff but then like
for me it was just weird
and i was just like it is
very friendly or just friendly well the
party that we were at to it's not a
bunch of strangers we're all friends
okay but then i just never seen her
uh in
kind of sitting on their laps and why i
don't remember what it was i was just
like i was like 21 or 22 or something
but then i was just like yo that's kind
of weird she goes why are you so jealous
like we're all friends here and i'm all
like i just never seen that before like
even if we're all friends i haven't seen
that close of a friendship it's just
weird you better sit on my dad's lap too
then yeah what the [ __ ]
why are you sitting on the lap like
there's plenty of [ __ ] room on the
couch here that's what's here make me
feel bad about this go sit on my dad's
lap
if you do this then i know you're normal
yeah then like you have no standards you
just sit on everybody's head wouldn't
wouldn't most guys feel weird if if a
girl was sitting on their lap and their
dude was right there like what
yeah yeah like the guy's stewing in the
corner yeah did everyone else in the
room know that she was in a relationship
with you because the more and more they
didn't know so you guys were secretly
yeah see this sounds made up yeah no
it's not made up
we were okay so it was in that stage of
like
we're we're talking about like oh what
are we you know and then so we're we're
establishing new boundaries right i
understand she's overcompensating to
hide it
let's ask her i don't know mind hunter
over what then what what happened after
that was i i said you know what this
kind of feels complicated i don't want
to go there because i don't like feeling
that way so i'm like we keep on [ __ ]
but i already said in my mind that i'm
not pursuing this any further
because it was too like
what the [ __ ] is this i love the
gangster in him we can keep on [ __ ]
but dude with an outfit like that
he's got a
fur mat what is what is in your lap now
where'd that come from pepper it's very
nice joe how long ago was your that
jealous moment for you i was like 21-21
you want to know a jealous moment i had
last weekend
it's more funny it's more funny than
anything
but i was uh i it was for my mom's
birthday like last weekend and we took
my mom out to she want to go to the
grove or some [ __ ] so we're walking
around the farmers market and my girl
was wearing this like really nice dress
and all these random people kept coming
up they were like oh my god your dress
is on green
whatever right guys are girls
uh girls no no guys would come up there
and come and address because if they do
we've scrapping yeah okay so i'm walking
i'm walking by my girl and then and then
uh there's this guy at this sandwich
place and i was looking at the sandwich
place i was like ooh because we're
trying to figure out what we want to eat
and i was like oh man this place has
reuben's
[ __ ] rubin like rubens too yeah i was
like oh they got the [ __ ] russian
dressing and i was like really hyped on
going to the sandwich place and i was
like that's the place i'm gonna go sound
crap i'm walking by the guy the guy who
yeah that's sour crap strawberry
pastrami or cornbread it was bald had
both and they had a combo so i was like
hyped i was like let's do double let's
double it up i don't buy bread too rye
bread it's not it's not a room and it's
not a ride exactly so true and i was
like and i was like this place looks
great and i was decided i'm gonna go eat
there
nice the guy who's working there starts
looking at my girl's ass
because of the dress she was wearing
the looking he was like looking at my
girl's ass and he was like kind of
looking and i was like just looking at
this dude and i was like mad dog because
i was like catch people the mean mod
starts yeah no but it wasn't like and he
i just he he looked down and then looked
at me and i looked at him and then he
looked away and i was like this
[ __ ] but it was like i was like
whatever but i was like i'm not gonna
eat this [ __ ]
i'm like i'm not gonna eat there dude no
[ __ ] your way bro look at my girl's ass
we're not going bro you didn't go you
you you didn't ask for a discount see
i'm that's my that's what i would do i
would tell i would tell my girl i'll be
like yo guess what bro it's not a
respect get me a [ __ ] free sandwich
how did you break and you heard why you
wanted to leave and guess i was guess
who was the real [ __ ] loser here you
i was like yeah i was i was the real
loser i lost he didn't get his reuben
because i didn't get the [ __ ] reuben
and you could have got a discount and
then you ain't gonna give me no [ __ ]
discount let's be real and i went to go
get another sandwich wasn't that good
hey it wasn't that good we'll go back
next week and it had no sides
the room in place had a side
how did that make you feel like how dare
you look at that
[ __ ]
plus i feel like i feel like if i had
fighting skills which i have zero of if
i had like if i knew i could at least
i do know i know you could break this i
got some nunchucks but uh
i feel like if i knew i could handle
somebody else right and somebody was
checking out goes that's i might smile
at his ass i might be like
you like that huh honestly i just and it
wasn't anything awkward like it was just
like he just looked at me and then he
just looked away and then i just looked
and then it was what was his look like
how obvious was it it was like it was
pretty obvious because sometimes i catch
people he goes like a santa fe was he
was he uh hispanic nah he was actually
an asian dude he probably watches the
show he was like he was like what if he
was a [ __ ] nick fan he was looking
and then look because the cakes were out
boy you know damn dude you're doing your
squats look at that bro he was behind
the counter and she we just happened to
walk lie and then he just was like
what yeah yeah he was like
and he was like leaning over the counter
a little bit
but it wasn't like it would it was did
he squeeze it was like a male male
bottle
it
yeah i never took you for a jealous guy
that's crazy dude i'm super [ __ ]
jealous i'm really thinking the only
time that i remember getting like
jealous
like truly jealous was i was in high
school the girl that had a crush on
brought a date to the school play that i
was in and they sat front row
and they were late to the show
and so i remember probably because of
her owning yeah
probably come on
probably and i remember seeing her in
the front row with this dude
and being like ah [ __ ]
but you know
but now i'm on tv so i don't give a [ __ ]
so
are all your guys's jealousy stories
like from 20 years ago
you had one last week i have another one
a month ago
you've got nothing to be jealous about
man michael are jealous of you my girl
my girl thinks tom holland is so cute
man [ __ ] tom holland bro hey like a
little brother cute
or like i want to [ __ ] him cute please
don't say those things um
but not little brother cute
she wants you to watch her [ __ ] that
dude she's a loser tell her tell her
he's a loser she wants she wants us to
shoot what the website did anyone watch
uncharted no was it good i don't know i
tried to stream it legally but it's a
video game movie does that make you
jealous which means
he's like also a good dancer so i'm a
little bit like dude todd is talented
stop talking about him i'm just saying i
respect his craft yeah that's a good
person for your girlfriend okay dude
celebrity question is not okay imagine
if she liked me how awkward would that
be like can you or like you you it's all
me baby
it's like do you want steve urkel or do
you want stefan it's still
i would definitely want stephan cause he
might get nerdy dude yeah but you never
know what he turns into in the bed i
like it when my girl has a crush on a
girl but not on a guy
[Laughter]
understatement
i think most straight men
would agree with that
what if the girl is like a trans and
looks really really manly like way more
manlier than you then that doesn't count
but when she but when she
she sends me her her crushes of the
month or whatever she's like this goes
so [ __ ] hot look at her and i'm like
i'm looking at her and she goes yeah
this is [ __ ] nice titties huh and i'm
like yeah dude are you a girl right now
like it sounds like a trap right yeah
yeah and then like you agree huh
yeah the way you're making her sound see
it it's like sick is her twitch what are
you thinking right now
you're like whoa relax you don't fall
for the trap i do
and then she gets jealous i'm just
kidding
but i think uh whenever yeah if it's a
girl just i think it's just something
about being straight or and stupid and
having a great imagination that one day
you're gonna have a threesome that makes
you go and yeah i'm very encouraging of
that and she's like wow that's so crazy
so if i had a lesbian lover and then
like i would steal time away like like
she would steal time away from me and
you guys you know you wouldn't be
jealous and i'm like [ __ ] no that'll be
tight she goes but you're not going to
be there though and i'm like that's fine
that's amazing it's the imagination that
makes me happy yeah i don't have and
plus it's like part time you know like
maybe sometimes i don't want to be there
seven days a week and you know you can
be there he's like i want to play video
games on friday and saturday night like
i don't need to go on a date she could
do that yeah but a guy though i gotta
play yakuza
yakuza let her eat your [ __ ] all night
for a moment you know like [ __ ] dude
like take a break i just keep saying
yakuza because i want anthony to yell it
yeah
there you go this is gonna be a running
commercial for sega and yakuza we should
get sponsored by sega sega sponsor us
please where has sega been you know the
japanese sega arcades that we went to
closed down so don't worry because
they're in yakuza
they're literally sega arcades in the
game where you can play sega video games
oh you can even play the crane games and
win wow oh when you're in akihabara the
electric district i think we should all
be characters in a video game
like as us in yakuza or be anything
jk jk news you wouldn't see us in lord
of the rings i'll tell you that yeah
there's no asian people in the [ __ ]
middle earth so i looked this up once
apparently
because i was like oh there's zero
asians there's zero black people there's
zero anybody and what are the rings so i
was like we're the people of color and
apparently there was an interview
yeah
tolkien said that the orcs represent the
people of color that's the ugly
[ __ ] orcs they're pretty to
someone
i was like
said no one i was like is this a
political statement
an entirely different body of land
they had to just be orcs i'm like isn't
this a fantasy like what's going on have
you ever been jealous anthony
of orcs he's been jealous
this is tom holland [ __ ] that guy dude
uh i don't know if jealousy is the right
word but just for the sake of fun
conversation i feel like i told some of
you guys of this instance in private uh
yeah um
there was one time where i i kind of
just started uh dating somebody you know
and uh it was like oh let's see where it
goes blah blah
but she was uh focusing on some other
like elements of her career so that
meant like sometimes like needing to
like hang out with different types of
like people you know what i'm saying
um and i just remember there was one
time where i was like hey maybe
we're gonna hang out at this time not
necessarily we were already dating so
it's just one of those like
not formal but we're gonna kick it we're
gonna hang out but then it was a date
minute yeah it was kind of like and last
minute she's like oh i gotta go you know
hang out these people do this type of
stuff but it was just one of those it's
not like a business formal event where
you're like wearing a suit and you're
like at a conference or like it's like a
it's like influencer stuff so you know
you have like a pool party or something
you know what i mean she's attracted to
hot tubs and stuff yeah yeah so i like
hot tubs there's nothing wrong with that
i actually respect the chase but i just
realized i didn't want to feel those
moments while somebody was like needing
to do what they need to do so i just
remember being like uh acknowledging i
was like [ __ ] i'm a little jealous but
it's like also kind of whack and i just
don't want to feel that all the time you
should have encouraged them to suck some
dick and climb the ladder
that's a real that's a real if you're a
real ally you would have said that i
think i think i
indirectly did by stepping out of the
way as well you know what i mean and
just being like you know like i i don't
want to be a part of this or feel this
so it's like but i want to see you have
to grab her hips lift her up while she
sucks a tall basketball player
like i said
i think there's technically nothing
wrong with doing what you got to do and
it wasn't like there was any wrong doing
it was just recognizing i didn't want to
feel i was you know through the journey
i want to see him do focus testing
because he'd probably be the wild card
yeah every group that's really wise
sometimes i just don't know what joe's
going to say and it surprises me every
single time sometimes i guess in my head
what he's going to say i'm always
always wrong you weren't surprised by
that basketball player no
like i didn't think he'd physically lift
her up i was like why did i think of
that before but that's also it's it's
it's literally a metaphorically support
you know what i mean
fulfills all sides so profound in uh
2000
already dude 2001
my ex um he must have been really
jealous he has a year i just remember
how it's just because it's so ridiculous
yeah i was jealous of my ex's ex
he he was not in our lives whatsoever
never saw him other than a photo but
that's all you need sometimes but every
time she gave you a hand job her hand
was like this first
and you're like why is that so big
why is that your default yeah where's
your default like why did you get i'm
over here
that's a soda can where's your diva like
that
grab the jabasco bottle
it's from grabbing the basketball are
you yawning yeah
did you just die
no i was jealous of him because he was
in prison
oh and i thought that was so [ __ ]
cool
your heroes were your your girlfriend's
ex-boyfriend joe camel
so like insecure that i was terrified
that
all the time everything i did i was like
[ __ ] she probably thinks he's so much
[ __ ] cooler because like they broke
up because he went to jail and i was
like we're out here
you're out here but your heart's in
their heart
she write him letters your heart's at
men's county
no they that's the thing is like they
[Music]
i i you look up visiting hours to see
when she forbade her from writing
letters i was like
that was like [ __ ] she was like is it
cool like if like we write letters and i
was like [ __ ] no and then of course she
did because i said no yeah like of
course you can do it he spin on his head
i couldn't even bag man back then
this was that's why he learned that's
why he learned how to spin on his head
you had to balance out the universe this
will get me in jail
did you feel like a placeholder no i
just
she didn't think this is the funny thing
i think a lot of guys do this dumb [ __ ]
she didn't at all think that he was
cooler than me whatsoever yeah i thought
he was cooler than me yeah and then like
because like back in 01 the only way to
be a cool asian was to be a bad asian
yeah there was no bad
getting to the highest level of kumon
wasn't on your like
what's it on your checklist because it
was a lot highest level like the highest
like i can do you know
calculus without a graphing calculator
like yeah or like the people at kumon
actually need my help exactly dude
that's what it turned into when people i
knew that kumon was a scam when the
instructor was like i can't figure out
why this equation is not working out and
i'm like tesh get in here i'm like it's
called pemdas if you figure that one out
you taught them about pet mouse yeah
that's crazy i just remembered uh i was
like oh he's probably not good looking
maybe he's just like a badass like dude
and then i i caught um i like caught her
letter to him and like i found a photo
of him i was like he's like [ __ ]
gorgeous
and it's really just a mug shot was he
might not want a mug shot dude he he
looked like that [ __ ] i don't know if
you guys remember this look from like
the late 90s early 2000s but the bald
asian [ __ ] nice ass jawline looked
like and he looked like a criminal
that's what i'm trying to go for and he
had the [ __ ] photo uh studio backdrop
the hot criminal look man that's tough
to beat that dude the hot criminal look
you're you're bored that's a lifestyle
yeah
can't pose that one no no no you can't
end up i like found it under her bed and
i was so mad because now
yeah because now i had a face to the
fear yeah i was like worse also the
boogeyman is now real was his name like
roman or something too like romeo or
some [ __ ] i knew it man
hey putting a face to a name is the
worst thing romeo or romell or something
like [ __ ] cool cause there's some
dudes that i met i remember i'm like
this is impossible to beat this guy his
name is out of a [ __ ] book he looks
like he's [ __ ] like he looks like i
want to jizz on him he just looks crazy
looks like i want to finish on his low
back i think i have an ego problem so
this never happens really yeah i'm the
i'm like ryan and any time i like me
when i was like courting uh tiff and
stuff i don't i used to get like so
insecure and jealous about [ __ ]
everything oh you name it it's all
self-inflicted too i was jealous of my
ex's [ __ ] stamp of her [ __ ] x on her
back because every time we doggy stout i
got i look down and i'm reminded what is
that space of her name
your ex had a tattoo of her ex on her
lower back of his face of his name what
was his name bart
[Laughter]
that'll be hilarious
this is a revenge story it all comes out
here you're about to take it's full
don't let it get to your head okay
full circle
i can feel you thinking it only took us
20 minutes to get there
but we did it youtube
[Music]
you